I want to UM want to ask you something
you have this move a flying knee where
you jump in the air you get your knee up
and your knees slams into the face of
the other person that is pretty much the
idea yeah yes exactly what I know right
watch the drew and you lift your knee
and you go flying and your knee comes up
and hits the person in the head and your
knee hits them and I'm thinking first of
all does the opponent have to be short
yes work we hit than that you hit the
nail on the head because obviously if
that your height yes listen I can't jump
that I don't play basketball for a
reason I can't jump high enough to knee
you in the head you I would kick in the
head
oh I thought you were just admitting
that in a fight I would win you know
because you'd be your knees would just
be glancing this way and that way and
I'd be up here going out but no you're
saying that you would have no problem
instead of the flying knee on me you
would just kick my head off yeah yeah I
would abandon the flying knee maneuver
you're too tall yeah go for a flying
kick right but this hair is a natural
cushion it certainly is I think I'd be
distracted by it yeah a lot of this and
then you'd get hypnotized and then Andy
would hit you with a chair from behind
Sulli plot
you